Simon you've just presented Greg with
the very first variety award for Fright
Fest tell me
those very first memories of horror fee
what made horror so important to you
both well for me I guess it was watching
films like America morph in London and
the thing and and laterally you know the
films of George Romero and I mean Day of
the Dead was when I was only 15 when I
saw day of the dead so that was the
first film I saw Greg in and that he
worked on so I get it you're younger
than me we should just talk about that
from see I would talk about movies like
The Exorcist Rosemary's Baby sort of you
were neat ideas before you earlier baby
what you did but you like he was like 20
when he did Day of the Dead it's not
like you were that old there I was old
enough let's put the age thing to the
side shall we Simon what's the most
uncomfortable or strangers makeup or
assess that you've had to have done to
you um I you know what when Greg made me
up for land of the dead I got to where
the really comfortable and I loved it
thanks I man I listen I haven't finished
my story I was Greg used the same
appliances that were used on Howard
Sherman and in Day of the Dead is bub so
I essentially got one of my favorite
zombies and it was amazing how
comfortable it was I spent maybe eight
or nine hours in it and I was almost
disappointed to take it off I found
there's something about immersing
yourself in a character you know even
going through the whole kind of like
head cast and stuff which is a very
claustrophobic experience it's actually
a lot of fun and I've never really had
to wear anything that hasn't been like
just a trip and that one particularly
because I was staring into the face of
my favorite zombie which is on my face
it was quite a wonderful thing so
everything Greg's ever done for me has
been very comfortable well put why
didn't I I should get an award for that
oye just gave me do you met with zombies
in fact didn't you Shaun of the Dead
brought us together did it's a good
decide they're dead but they brought us
together we met just because Greg had
seen shaun of the dead are legendarily
on a snide copy which he didn't realize
was a snow copy and then bought friends
to see it
and bought ken foree to see that comic
con and and we met Edgar mean met
afterwards and you know obviously were
introduced to someone we both admired
and we just kind of hit it off Greg was
like us you know it was a horror fan
that go into horror and and you know
that was extremely heartening for us as
kind of like would be filmmakers to see
someone so experienced and so kind of
well known to be exactly like we were
you know which is just a fan it's an
admiration that comes you know when you
you know everyone knows how hard it is
to get a movie made so let alone a movie
that's entertaining it's fun that takes
you on a journey so when I had seen
shaun of the dead I wanted to know more
about it I wanted to know who the people
were they made it and how how it was so
clever and so interesting and funny and
and scared all at the same time so I
think what happens is in this industry
we get fortunate enough to be able to
seek out people who inspire us and
ultimately get a chance to work together
so when we met it was like I'm not
worthy no I'm not worthy then we got
into a fight no I'm not worthy no I'm
not joking I was whether it's a very
first movie that put special effects
makeup in your mind you know I would I
would honestly say probably a 7th voyage
of Sinbad because when I was really
young before video existed you would
have to purchase these little super 8
movies and you could watch them over and
over again so you'd string it up and
you'd watch it on the sheet in the
basement and I would watch them reverse
forward backwards over and over again
and seeing the Cyclops coming out of the
cave and that first flight was really
probably one of the first solid memories
I had of special-effects and of course
from that point going from there and
then understanding makeup and seeing the
Exorcist and seeing later like Dawn of
the Dead and things like that but
definitely I think Harryhausen piqued my
interest in special effects cuz that was
really all all I knew that and like you
know creature from the black lagoon in
Frankenstein you know the fact that they
constructed it all out of putty when
they built Frankenstein and you know
reading the stories about when they
would put the hair on the wolfman i'm
using him as my model
and then after they would glue it on
they would take a hot iron and singe the
hairs so that the hairs were all even
and no wonder lon chaney hated being in
makeup because he SAT there smelling
burned air for four hours there I just
ruined everything you've been in the
industry for a number of years now how
do you see an effects change in that
time effects of change considerably I
mean you know ultimately our
contribution is very hands-on sculpting
mold-making it's something physical are
the artists that I work with their
brilliant because they can take clay and
transform it into the scariest zombie or
the greatest character makeup they
certainly have changed in regards to the
fact that digital effects and visual
effects have changed the landscape of
special-effects the thing that I find
encouraging is it's a tool just like
visual effects makeup practical effects
it's really up to the director to sort
of utilize each of those techniques to
service the movie and the more and more
people that are younger that come into
the industry that were inspired by the
movies that we were inspired by they'll
still go back and watch day of the dead
and they'll still go back and watch the
howling and American world from London
and ultimately though but they're like I
want to make a movie like that I want to
make a fake head that can transform into
a werewolf so we do have a lot of people
whose inspiration is now pushing makeup
effects and continuing that trend which
I which I love guys it's let me to speak
to you thank you so much
you